[Music]
this last duty this constitutes the
perfect divine law or the positive
ethical action towards the individual
every other relationship to him which
does not remain one simply of love but
as ethical belongs to human law and has
the negative significance of raising the
individual above his confinement within
the natural community to achieve in his
natural existence belongs now although
human right has for its content and
power the actual ethical substance that
is conscious of itself that is the
entire nation while the divine right and
law has for its content and power the
individual who is beyond the real world
yet he is not without power his power is
the abstract pure universal the
elemental individual which equally draws
back into the pure abstraction which is
its essence the individuality that
breaks loose from the element and
constitutes the self conscious reality
of the nation drawing it back into the
essence which is its ground how this
power is manifested in the notion itself
we shall see in the ensuing development
in paragraph four
hundred and fifty three Hegel is going
to specify a bit more about what he is
calling this last duty this left the
flick toward the dead individual who is
a member of the family on the part of
the blood relative so he tells us two
things that are very interesting here is
ways in which he characterizes this last
Duty says this constitutes the perfect
divine law and it the positive ethical
action hond lung in german towards the
individual and let's talk about the
second one first we'll come back to the
first one in a bit he says every other
relationship to him to the person who
has died which does not remain one
simply of love that is love in terms of
the faction right or natural desire but
as ethical belongs to human law and he
has the negative significance of raising
the individual above his confinement
within the natural community to which he
and his natural existence belongs so
Hegel is not denying one bit that within
the community the nation the people
whatever you want to concede that the
culture there are going to be a lot of
norms surrounding what our comportment
ought to be toward the dead for example
if you look at any particular modern
state you're going to find the whole set
of arrangements often down at the local
level here in our United States
pertaining to burial customs and rites
and what's allowable and what's not and
what has to be done with with the bodies
of the dead there may be money set aside
for burying or otherwise disposing of
those who nobody comes to claim so that
is a way of treating the individual as
an individual and
we have all the other things that go
along with it inheritance you know all
of that is is over here and then we have
love over here which Hegel says that's
nice if you've got it but that's not yet
an ethical relation so what is the
ethical relation that is this last duty
it's something beyond that and we're
going to come back to that in a moment
so now now Hegel sketches out a sort of
dichotomy of splitting a contrast which
is going to eventually become a full-on
conflict between human law and right
uses the terms you know wrecked here as
well as Gazette and divine law and here
we have an interesting transformation
notice what Hegel doesn't talk about he
doesn't talk about the gods he doesn't
talk about divine law as something that
comes down from on high through some
sort of revelation instead it's it's
something else that is you might say
rising up from below within the matrix
of the family and the blood relation
what is the divine here that's the
question we want to ask so he says
although human law or you human right
rather has for its content and power the
actual ethical substance that is
conscious of itself that is the entire
nation the entire community while the
divine right in law has for its content
and power notice what he says the
individual beyond the real world so what
do we have here we have a contrast
between not just you might say the
public and the private but between the
universal in the sense of everybody and
the universal in the sense of me the
individual we also have a contrast here
in terms of what is manifest versus what
is hidden
but even more so than apparent contrast
as Hegel is going to tell us between
what is powerful and what has no power
why do the dead have no power because
they as the dead they no longer belong
to the real world they are no longer
view click they're no longer doing
things out there in public unless we're
going to you know have something like a
weekend at Bernie's sort of example
which you know has been done politically
in some cases but in that case it's the
living using the dead as a prop it's not
the dead him or herself Hegel says
they're not powerless his power is the
abstract pure universal the elemental
individual which equally draws back into
the pure abstraction which is its
essence the individuality that breaks
loose from that element and constitutes
the self conscious reality of that
nation draws it back into the essence
which is its ground now when you read
that you might say what can power that
that doesn't sound like power to do
anything that just sounds like a bunch
of abstractions about abstraction well
there is a power there it is the power
of being something different that
disrupts that doesn't fit in that
subverts this you know bright open
system where everybody's relating to
each other in we might say the world
above how is that going to play itself
out Hegel says we're not quite there yet
how this power is manifested in the
notion itself we shall see in the
ensuing development so he is just
putting this idea out there he's that
thing I'm defining how this power works
at this point but he is prepping us for
it now notice again I want to stress
this perfect divine law
but a divine law which at this point in
time is not the God telling us what to
do but something else going on how does
this divine law play itself out why does
it have to do with the family in this
last duty these are the questions that
we're now going to explore
now in the one law as in the other there
are also differences and gradations for
since both laws have within them the
moments of consciousness difference is
developed within the laws themselves and
this constitutes their movement and
their own peculiar life consideration of
these differences reveals the way in
which they operate and the mode of self
consciousness of the two universal
essential nature's of the ethical world
and also their connection and transition
into one another
here in this very short paragraph number
450 for Hegel it's still setting the
scene and now he's bringing us almost
right up to the very edge of analyses of
the human and divine law and he's
suggesting to us that first we need to
examine each of these in its own
development and then we can look at how
they come into a competition or conflict
with each other and and what ensues from
that so he tells us that in the one law
as in the other there are differences
and gradations so neither of these laws
is something perfectly simple really
makes sense in terms of human law if you
think about how complex the norms
governing any particular society are
we're often tempted when we're doing in
a historical presentation or
reconstruction to oversimplify and say
about you know particular people that
there's a there's a principle around
which their entire life is organized it
never really turns out to be quite like
that or if there is something that's
identifiable as a principle from a
Hegelian perspective that always sort of
unfolds itself and shows us that there's
a whole bunch of different principles at
play and that there and get you know
they're they're involved with each other
and oftentimes in you know antithesis
with each other and that has to be
worked out so there are going to be
gradations you know higher and lower
there is going to be what you know Hegel
is calling movement differences being
developed within each of these and
that's important to keep in mind
remember that in this discussion of
spirit we're getting closer and closer
to the concrete we're still engaged in a
process that the bit removed from it as
you know carrying out phenomenological
analyses and we are engaged in some very
high you know looking at it from from a
above sort of generalizing but we do
want to try to be as concrete as
possible however difficult that may be
so he says why is why is it that there
are differences in gradations both laws
have within themselves the moment of
consciousness so what is this involved
there is difference developed within the
laws themselves and this difference he
says constitutes their movements and
their life each of these is a living law
so the differences that are coming about
by the mere fact that these are laws for
conscious beings was of conscious beings
laws by conscious beings means that
there's going to be some splitting going
on some differentiation and some some
movement within them so he says if we
consider these differences we're going
to understand the ways in which they
operate that's what we really want to
understand we don't want to assume for
example that human law and divine law
are really the same thing since we've
got law in the first place and divine
law is just sort of a projection of
human law that would be a mistake Hegel
things we also don't want to go the
other way and say oh well we just take
the divine law and human law is all
based on that Hegel is really trying to
take account of the fact that we are
dealing with two complex things two
complex manifestations of spirit of
Geist of mind in history that we we
don't want to lose sight of by by
substituting our own forced alone in our
own representation our own picture
thinking for them and this is the vice
of many social theories of trying to be
over simplistic about this or dismissing
one side and only focusing on the other
side so Hegel says that if we consider
these differences we'll see the way in
which they operate beyond the mode of
self consciousness of the two universal
essential nature's of the ethical world
these are why did Hegel pick these
he does think these are the two
universal essential nature's of the
ethical world at least at this point in
development of spirit of the development
of human consciousness so he goes on and
he says we'll also get to see their
connection and transposition into one
another so like I just began by saying
first we want to examine how these two
laws do develop and then we're going to
look at how they connect up with each
other and where the areas in which they
come into conflict are and how those
conflicts get get worked through
the community the superior law whose
validity as openly apparent has its real
vitality of the government as that in
which it has a individual form
government is the reality of spirit that
is reflected in to itself the simple
self of the entire ethical substance
this simple power does indeed allow the
family to expand into its constituent
members and to give to each part and
enduring being and a being for self of
its own spirit has in this it's reality
or its objective existence and the
family is the element of this reality
but spirit is at the same time the power
of the whole which brings these parts
together again into a negative unity
giving them the feeling of their lack of
Independence and keeping them aware that
they have their life only in the whole
the community may on the one hand
organize itself into systems of personal
independence and property of laws
relating to persons and things and on
the other hand the various ways of
working for ends which are in the first
instance particular ends those of gain
and employment it may articulate into
their own special and independent
associations the spirit of universal
assembly and Association is the simple
and negative essence of those systems
which tend to isolate themselves in
order to not to let them become rooted
and set in this isolation thereby
breaking up the whole and letting the
communal spirit evaporate government has
from time to time to shake them to their
core by war why this means the
government upsets their established
order and violates their right to
independence while the individuals who
absorbed in their own way of life break
loose from the whole and strive after
the inviolable independence and security
of the person are made to feel in the
task laid on them their lord and master
death spirit by thus throwing into the
melting pot the stable existence of
these systems checks their tendency to
fall away from the ethical order and to
be submerged in a merely natural
existence and it preserves and raises
conscious self into freedom and its own
power the negative essence shows itself
to be the real power of the community
and the force of its self-preservation
the community therefore
this is the truth and the confirmation
of its power in the essence of the
divine law and in the realm of the
netherworld
here in this longer paragraph 455 Hegel
is beginning to sketch out for us just
how the human law works and you notice
that by the very end of this it's going
to whether it likes it or not end up
bringing in the divine law as almost
like it's a inescapable shadow but first
what Hegel is going to do is sketch out
for us a very you know oversimplified
version this isn't in his finished view
on this but what we need at this point
in time about how the human law works
for the ethical community in terms of
its constituent parts in what we might
call its driving or dominating part then
he's going to talk about one of the key
functions that that keeps what we could
call a ethical motifs and motivations in
play against a counter tendency for
those to gradually settle out and be
replaced by other other intentions and
and processes so he uses this term a
community or what Miller's translating
his community here combined disease and
literally the essence of what is in
common right and he's using this instead
of using the other terms that he has
been employing like folk you know the
nation as how that's usually translated
or the people and shot just Trant you
know translated by by its cognate state
and here he's talking about something
that would encompass those but those of
course include elements of the state and
does include elements of the the folk
and he's placing all of these into
relation with each other so he says the
community and he called it the superior
law whose validity is openly apparent
right the the human law which is
aboveboard as we've said
manifest to all and they says it has its
vitality in the government this is a
term that he's already used that a year
on the rulership though the the
sovereign authority whatever we want to
call it the Magister see the people who
make sure that things get done right the
the coordinators so he says that they
have the real vitality in the government
as that in which it has an individual
form the government is where this is
consolidated and given agency so
government is the reality of spirit that
is reflected into itself the simple self
of the entire ethical substance so in
the way in which it understands itself
in its own activities and its relations
to other elements or or portions or
dimensions of the community this is how
spirit through the human law gets to
know itself and continually understands
itself and expands itself and contracts
itself in certain ways and reinterprets
itself so I mean the government can of
course change hands but this
governmental function is going to be
central in the entire way in which the
human law plays itself out so he goes on
and he says this simple power does
indeed allow the family to expand into
its constituent members so in addition
to a government within a state we have
the family and indeed as I put here
plural families right and within each of
these families there is a certain scope
of independence and freedom within that
that framework so unless the state is
getting very nosy and delving into
certain families which you know a
certain point it probably has to do you
know particularly in modern states the
family is a place where where these
relations can develop which which allows
these individuals the members of the
family to be developed within
that scope and so what we have here is
an interplay between the government and
the families that are allowed their own
scope and the government is over the
families the government may in fact be
run by a family and then things get very
very messy right but the family does get
to expand into its constituent members
and to give to each part of enduring
being and being for self of its own we
saw this for example just in the past
paragraphs in terms of funerary rites
right so he goes on and he says spirit
has in this it's reality or its
objective existence and the family is an
element of this reality so the family is
an element of the working of the human
law within the law of the community the
government is superior to the family
within this because the government
embodies spirit in the sense of the
human law knowing itself unfolding
itself applying itself to the activities
of families doesn't mean that it takes
over the family entirely as a matter of
fact you get the idea
that Hegel thinks that that would not
just here in this place but also his
other end that would be a terrible idea
the family actually has a function we
don't want to simply replace it with
some surrogate of the state or the
government so he goes on and he says
spirit is at the same time the power of
the whole which brings these parts
together in again into a negative unity
giving them the feeling of their lack of
Independence keeping them aware that
they have their life only in the whole
now he doesn't expel this out but this
is worth reflecting on this feeling of
not being totally independent of being
part of the whole it's easy to see how
that would fit into the family because
the family can like walk outside and
realize that they live on a street in a
city which is run by other people
not in that family right you exit the
house and you're now within the the
larger community what about the
government is the government aware of a
similar although not on the exact same
grounds lack of independence yes and no
when government thinks that they are the
totality of the community that's usually
a sign that things have gone off the
rails isn't it and things are going to
get very bad when the government is
aware of its own limited nature then
there's a sort of internal contradiction
going on on the one hand they are spirit
reflected into itself they are the ones
who speak for the community on the other
hand they have to be aware that they are
not the totality of the community that
there are other other things other
rational beings that can present
themselves against the government Hagel
then talks about something else
something that allows what he called
special and independent associations
this we might think of as the economic
life and the civil society life within
the community something that is not just
of the families where people are related
to each other through reproduction blood
ties all of those sorts of associations
and not just a matter of government and
its many different you know tentacles
reaching into other things but how
individuals and families and perhaps
even governmental agencies associate
with each other into a purpose or
organization that is different than that
of government and different than that
merely of the family so he says the
community may on the one hand organize
itself in the systems of personal
independence and property
now that does involve the family right
and that does also involve the
government or the state if you like
because Hegel is going to point out this
involves laws relating to persons and
things but that's not all that's going
on this tends to take on a sort of life
of its own we've seen this even more in
the second motif that he brings up on
the other hand the various ways of
working for ends which are in the first
instance particular ends those of gain
and enjoyment it may articulate into
their own special and independent
associations what does this mean
these are workplaces these are companies
these are places where buying and
selling goes on these are ways in which
transactions take place and notice that
the systems of persons and property in
the ways of working towards these
interviews with each other so on the one
hand we could say well look this is
primarily a matter of the government and
has to do with this this is coming the
other way and this is what nourishes it
allows there to be a political economy
in the first place that then the
government might have some insight into
right and there's more to it than just a
political economy this is the entire
class of what Locke called voluntary
associations what the Tocqueville in his
time called intermediate associations
this could be your bridge club this
could be a brewing Association of people
who are interested not just in making a
buck but in making good beer this could
be a chess club this could be all sorts
of other things this could be a
foundation that's established for
helping out those whose families are in
terrible situations where the the
charity of the government is unable to
to see or even to you know
to effectively reach all of this is part
of the community all of this is the
totality of the community now notice
what Hegel says next here we take a
little bit of an interesting turn so he
says the spirit of universal assembly
and Association is the simple and
negative essence of those systems which
tend to isolate themselves all of this
stuff over here tends to isolate itself
Hegel says that one of the roles of
government is shaking stuff up keeping
these from declining out of the realm of
the ethical into the non ethical now how
does it do that war war is how it does
it conflict he says in order to not let
them become rooted and set in their
isolation thereby breaking up the whole
in letting the communal spirit evaporate
government has from time to time to
shake them to their core by war where we
seen this shaking to the core before in
the master-slave dialectic well actually
just before it and then right after it
is in the master-slave dialectic right
the two consciousness is confront each
other one is shaken to its core gives in
that becomes the slave both of them are
willing to brave death now it's no
longer the master becoming the one who
braved death more and thereby subjugate
the slave no the government is the one
that sets everyone into war or puts the
nation at risk or however you want to
think about it so it's more complicated
don't read master-slave dialectic
into this rather read what this shaken
to the core could be into that he says
by this means the government upsets
their established order violates their
right to independence why because the
government asserts look the community
matters more than trade associations or
you know even the systems of law and
property which may need
be set aside for the time being you can
think for example of you know wartime
impositions like abolishing a habeas
corpus here in the United States you
know things that happen during the Civil
War World War One World War two and on
into the war on terror right so he says
the individuals who absorbed in their
own way of life break loose from the
whole and strive after the inviolable
independence and security the person are
made to feel in the task laid on them
their Lord and Master and again
harkening back to the self consciousness
section who is the ultimate master death
now here is where the government acting
on behalf of the community or the
superior law the human law he has bitten
off more than it can successfully chew
let alone digest now it's going to bring
in the divine law whether it likes it or
not
he says spirit by throwing into the
melting pot of stable existence of these
systems checks their tendency to fall
away from the ethical order and to be
submerged into merely natural existence
and it preserves and it raises cannot
itself into freedom and its own real
power
however there's something else going on
the negative essence shows itself to be
the real power of the community what is
the real power of the community the fact
that it can compel right the force of
its all of its self-preservation the
community says therefore possesses the
truth and the confirmation of its power
in the essence not of the human law but
of the divine law and in the realm of
the nether world
what is the nether world we're going to
going to explore that a little bit here
in a bit the nether world is not a
second world underneath this world it's
the world that you can't see IAT Hades
is what how we translate it in English I
eighties that which is not seen the
invisible world now we have a lot more
yet to sketch out but you
scene two important movements Hegel's
sketching out how things are developing
and then this need to make sure that
these do not fall away from the ethical
the government making this this movement
of throwing them into some sort of
crisis or battle or war and then that
you know reintroducing for the
potentially no longer ethical
individuals something else I've seen
something that can connect them to the
community and yet at the other on the
other end places them in relation to
death
you